so how did you make this movie back-end
night I'm looking at it and just
wondering this was pre digital this no
computers where did this idea come from
and how did it happen
we started in 1981 we wrote a couple of
drafts
we've been out at 30 years I think I
showed Geoffrey and Michael Eisner came
in they then went through all the
archives I guess and somehow it found
its way to Steven and we had done a
movie together we did back to the future
together and he you know he said you
know I read this said I read this this
crazy screenplay
over at Disney and I said Roger ever
said I said I know that I know that
screenplay and we kind of looked at each
other and we said could we actually do
this you know pull this off well there
are a lot of moments the studio had
serious moments where they didn't think
we were going to get it done but yeah
there were moments the whole you know I
remember when I went in I tried to
figure out what's the the peak capacity
for ILM you know it in order to get this
movie done and that's and how many weeks
can they sustain that and that was
really what we were really flying by the
seat of our pants to get this thing done
I mean everyone told us you had to lock
the camera down yeah there are all these
rules associated with how they did it on
Mary Poppins I know something like that
and that's the only other operable thing
I can think yeah or eats dragon or
something so we I learned really quick
on this movie you just say yes you say
you want to move the camera yes move the
camera you want to have Jessica's dress
glitter yes we'll figure that out and we
didn't have a clue how he would do it
but by moving the camera it meant we had
to animate on ones which meant we had to
do 24 drawings instead of 12 drawings a
second and it would there were no
computer so there were there was no
tracking software that was all done by
hand and and it was like pencils and
paint and and the most amazing
technology was I got a fax machine
halfway through the production which I
turned off right after I got it so we
thought that Jessica would be like one
of the classic movie stars
like with a bigger chest really all
right
I mean it's kind of surprising to see
how big all those things are in the
movie it seems kind of immature when you
look back on it I was amazing how
naughty we were when I saw this movie
and how did we get away with that pop it
was the 80s
you know one thing I wanted to say was a
weak force maybe today when we first
started working on it we had a big
problem as to how to convey the fact
that humans did you know commingle with
cartoon characters and Roger was not
famous you know only in our mind so we
we thought well how do we how do we do
this so Peter and I wrote that cartoon
and that cartoon was always from the
very first draft we ever wrote was
always how the movie started because it
introduced Roger and baby Herman in
their relationship I came onto a little
bit later when I came onto it when I
flew to London the guys were finishing
up the cartoon and I started on the
ostrich scene that was my first scene
straight from the airport which Williams
here's your first scene welcome to
London and that was the ostrich one that
was my first one the very first shot
that was finished in in complete
animation was the chili bottle sliding
down the Shelf to the camera from the
opening cartoon that was us so that was
the very first thing we could get
something done and it was a very
elaborate hand-drawn shot because it's
perspective is moving right and so it
was all done by hand and it's perfected
and it was all done in London and they
spelled the word chilli wrong it had it
had two L's in it the whole shot had to
be kind of had to be redone that
happened you can just use the consultant
right I didn't think iron and that's the
kind of memory flashbacks I was having
watching the movie that what was the set
like but wasn't really playing against
nothing because Charlie was rabbit suit
every day really so he was and yes
inside I remember hearing something did
Charles that you invent something called
trans projection alack ting
that's correct we caught at EPA on the
set yeah but so you created that well I
don't think there have been an
opportunity for it to arise previously
so Kay how did it work what is what is
trans projection all acting
how does out well it's where you're off
camera with a special microphone and
you're watching what's going on in the
set and projecting yourself into that
space so if Bob were to Bob Hoskins
where to grab my ears I would have to
react to that hence the projection he
hit himself on the head on the camera a
lot as he was projecting I'd saw him
jump up and bang his head so there's a
speech impediment after I'd already been
employed they inform me that they need a
speech impediment of some kind
after all classic cartoon characters
have to have a speech in yeah and the
good ones were mostly taken so you know
you don't want to impede on summons
impediment which is not recommended to
even say and then I I guess because of
Hunt's halt I sing him both and I used
to do bits about the aliens and horses
and that came into the the play and Bob
Z I didn't put it all together and
what's it sound like
Louise tippers I could never do it here
mad at the Academy
you